good morning Hank it's Tuesday so Bill
and Melinda Gates his annual letter just
came out and it really is my favorite
letter of the year with apologies to the
birthday card I get every year from my
insurance agent you should read the
whole thing link below but it predicts
that in the next 15 years the lives of
the world's poorest people will become
dramatically better
all right so even though hundreds of
millions of people have emerged from
absolute poverty in the last 25 years
and even though child mortality has been
cut by half and even though more kids
than ever have access to vaccinations we
still kind of live in two worlds in one
world fewer than 1% of kids die before
the age of five almost no one gets
malaria very few children are denied
access to vaccines because of lack of
refrigeration and serious malnutrition
and children is extremely uncommon and
then we have the other world in that
11.5 million kids die every year from
diseases that could be easily prevented
by vaccines Sarah like 200 million cases
of malaria every year and more than 25%
of kids are stunted due to malnutrition
which can lead to cognitive problems and
all kinds of other health issues and in
this world kids are far less likely to
go to school or to learn how to read
especially if they're girls and all of
that is totally unacceptable it's also
unnecessary so global child mortality is
dropped by half in the last 25 years and
the Gates letter argues that in the next
15 years it can drop by half again and
this is achievable without expensive
specialists or new medical procedures
how first breastfeeding infants who are
breastfed for six months are 14 times
more likely to survive second access to
cheap injectable antibiotics which could
save 300,000 kids a year then you've got
inexpensive hand-pumped oxygen masks
which could prevent a third of infant
deaths worth drawing the baby and
offering skin-to-skin contact to keep it
warm
and lastly keeping the umbilical cord
free from infection this can actually be
done with an ingredient found in my
mouthwash literally before moving on
here quick reminder that cutting infant
mortality does not lead to population
explosions in the long run in fact quite
the opposite the kids what are also
talks about a bunch of other investments
and innovations that will improve the
lives of poor people like access to
mobile banking and better farming
practices and online education tools and
I just want to imagine for a moment what
that world would look like enough food
would be produced in Africa to feed
every African the 2.5 billion people
without a bank account would be able to
save and dramatically simplify their
economic
lives with access to mobile banking
girls would have far better educational
opportunities dramatically reducing the
gender gap in literacy holy Oh river
blindness and guinea worm diseases that
kill or disabled tens of millions of
people wouldn't even exist anymore and
half the kids who are gonna die today
would not die ensure the world's people
would be healthier and better educated
and more productive and that would be
good for all of us because here's the
thing we do not actually live in two
worlds it sometimes feels like we do not
just because no one in my neighborhood
has kids who are stunted due to
malnutrition but because no one I follow
on tumblr or Twitter or Instagram has
kids who are I think the reach of my
online life can feel infinite but it
isn't and that inevitably creates an
empathy gap as Bill and Melinda put it
in the letter there is overwhelming
evidence that people care about others
who are suffering when they can see that
suffering but too often we can't see it
not because people in the developing
world are silent but because we're not
good at listening to them we're far
better at listening to voices that feel
closer that we can find on tumblr or
Twitter people who feel like us but the
way we imagine us must include people
living in poverty because there is just
the one world and when we start to pay
attention to problems that seem distant
and foreign we often find that they
actually aren't they're human problems
they're us problems Hank I think the
coolest thing about the Gates letter
this year is that they give us the
opportunity to learn to listen better
and more broadly by signing up to be
something they call a global citizen the
idea is that if we become more informed
about the issues facing people around
the world we will naturally become more
engaged I think that's brilliant and I
hope it allows me at least to learn to
listen better so I hope you'll join me
in signing up link in the doobly-doo
hank by the way I also hope that we're
still making videos in 15 years so we
can discuss which of the Gates letter
predictions came true and which didn't
but before then in fact significantly
before then I will see you on Friday